space is important to me
it's what sets the mood and tone a space
can bring forward thoughts that have
been dormant or
forming in my mind and depending on the
space
it can allow me to be completely
vulnerable with myself and explore the
world and myself
without judgment i've been spending a
lot of time at home this year like
everybody else
and i've been making my home a place
where i feel comfort
safety and joy this last year was also
the first time that i worked full time
for myself
it was my first full year working from
home
i like to think of my space as a thing
that molds
and changes right alongside me and
reflects my current needs
state of mind and aesthetic through the
different stages
of my life in japanese culture there's a
kind of belief that there's spirit
in everything in both living things and
not
i used to interpret this as a child that
every single one
of not just my toys and stuffed animals
were alive
but also things like my desk my
toothbrush
my blanket and the pens that i used for
school
in fact i used to think that if i didn't
spread the use of my pens and pencils
evenly
then the ones i don't use often would
feel left out
so i'd pick those up too and now that
i'm older
i still think there is spirit in the
things you surround yourself with
maybe not in quite the same way as i did
when i was younger
but i think about how what you surround
yourself with
can create a unique environment for
yourself
and because i've been spending so much
time with my beloved things
i wanted to share with you some of my
favorite things in my room
that have brought me joy this last year
this picture ledge is something i made a
few weeks ago
filling my space with things that i made
by myself
reminds me that i have the ability to
make something from nothing and that
with some skill building
i can surprise myself with what i can do
i also really like my space to reflect
some element of nature too i kind of
almost feel like
i need some level of natural entropy to
be happening within my space
in order for my brain to buzz in the way
that i want it to
so the natural curves and grain of the
wood is something i made sure to have
stand out
when making this piece i filled it with
a few pieces of art that i really admire
all speaking a different language to me
about creativity
and having beauty in your life this is
also something that i made pretty
recently
i've always wanted an edison bulb in my
room because i love the warm glow
that's not too dark or too bright i
found the light itself from the color
cord company
but when it came to mounting it all the
ways i saw online
didn't really spark anything in me i
came up with a design that i liked
and made this with a few pieces of wood
from my local hardware store
at night it looks really pretty and
while i generally
like well-lit spaces the soft glow gives
my room a sense of coziness
that i love having in a space the next
two are things that are important
members of my desk setup
the first is a macbook stand my macbook
is my main workhorse for
everything that i do but i rarely ever
use the screen and keyboard that it
comes with
instead of opting for something bulky or
metallic
i found the stand on grovemade that i've
been adoring for a while
they graciously gifted me this one after
i reached out
and i love it so much the wool lining
feels like my macbook is being cradled
safely and i just
really love the wood grain too my pen
stand was also gifted
and i love how soft the edges are it
almost kind of feels like a mini tree
that hosts my writing utensils
for a little party
i love keyboard clocks a lot
i think my brain likes it because clacky
keyboards reminds me of
a former generation and so the sound in
and of itself
is nostalgic to me it reminds me of the
times in computer labs
the times when i'd go on my dad's apple
computer
and of my emac in high school that came
with a bluetooth mechanical keyboard
i loved that keyboard right now i'm
using the keycon
k2 with gateron brown switches and it
just
sounds so nice i feel like that along
with whatever music i'm playing through
my speakers
is a theme song to my room it's a
relaxing
and reassuring sound that time is moving
forward
gently and softly
lastly is my diffuser being on a
computer
often makes me forget that i'm a human
being with five senses
so i guess i really like objects that
remind me that i am
in fact human so i love this diffuser i
have from muji
this was my birthday gift to myself last
year since i'd been eyeing this one for
years
but it's easy one of my favorite things
in my room the gentle mist
the color the warbling sound
and of course whatever scent i put in
for that day instantly puts me
into the mood to create relax do work
or nap i most often use this hinoki
scent
it's japanese cypress and it's both
relaxing
and refreshing at the same time it's
amazing to me that the things you
surround yourself with
can transport you to another world
without
really ever having to leave granted
while i wish we weren't in a pandemic
and we could leave to explore the world
and reunite with our loved ones
i've grown to have so much gratitude for
not just the people in my life
but my things too while silent
i love that they're by my side as i show
up every day
to do life
[Music]
you